bonjour à chacun et à chacune d'entre
vous nous nous retrouvons donc dans le
cadre de notre mission d'information sur
la précarisation paupérisation et cet
après midi sera consacrée à un échange
sur la précarité alimentaire
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir les
représentants de cinq organisations
actives en matière de lutte contre la
précarité alimentaire
donc monsieur yves brion et lui quand tu
elle responsable des relations
institutionnelles des restons des restos
du coeur et je crois que vous êtes en
visio monsieur yan auger directeur
général de l'association nationale des
épiceries solidaires
je vois aussi vidéo merci monsieur
nicolas champion membre du bureau
national du secours populaire en visio
également que je bonjour bah voilà
très bien merci et jean baptiste fa
watier président de l'ordre de malte
france que je vois également bonjour à
tous monsieur claude baland merci d'être
présent avec nous dans cette salle donc
vous êtes président de la fédération
française des banques alimentaires
donc je vous remercie tous d'avoir
accepté l'invitation du sénat
notre mission d'information est chargé
de comprendre et de proposer des
solutions face au phénomène de
précarisation et de paupérisation d'une
partie des français c'est-à-dire au
mouvement de fragilisation qui frappe
certains de nos concitoyens non
seulement dans la crise actuelle mais au
cours des dernières années et notamment
depuis la dernière crise
et c'est vrai que le coc vide nous a
fait vivre un événement exceptionnel là
aussi sur le fait que des personnes
basculent dans la précarité alors qu'il
nice ne s'y attendait pas je vous
propose sur la forme donc de débuter
cette audition par un bref propos
liminaire de 7 8 minutes chacun qui
permettra de bien identifier le rôle
reste
tif de vos organisations vous pourriez
également nous faire part de vos
principaux constats canto grande
tendance observable d'évolution de
précarité alimentaire notamment quant
aux nouvelles populations qui font appel
à vos services depuis la crise liée à
l'épidémie du commis de 19 mais aussi
auparavant le cas échéant nous ouvrirons
ensuite une phase d'échangé en
commençant par les questions de madame
la rapporteure madame frédérique puissat
et ensuite par les questions des
sénateurs et sénatrices qui sont
présents dans cette salle ou à distance
également et qui sont membres de notre
mission d'information je vous rappelle
que cette audition fera l'objet d'une
captation vidéo qui sera retransmise en
direct sur le site internet du sénat et
sera consultable à la demande en vidéo
donc messieurs mérillon et quand tu elle
je vais peut-être commencer par vous
donc et vous laisser la parole en je
sais pas oui mais voila sinon veillant
sur les prix je vais commencer louis
temps tu elle pourra compléter
merci d'abord de cette invitation à un
moment où un an après le début de la
crise nous avons beaucoup de réflexions
qui nous interroge sur remplissons nos
missions peut-être d'abord juste un
petit une petite photo aujourd'hui nous
aidons à peu près neuf cent mille
personnes qui avant la crise nous
faisons ça avec 75 mille bénévoles dans
2000 centre ou en france et nous
distribuons chaque année 135 millions de
repas un point qui est important c'est
que nous sommes pas seulement une
association d aide alimentaire c'est
quelque chose qui est fondamental pour
nous l'aide alimentaire est la porte
d'entrée vers toute une série
d'activités d'action d'inclusion sociale
que ce soit le soutien à la recherche
d'emploi qu'ils étaient amants
fondamental l'accès aux cultures à la
culture
le microcrédit lé conseil budgétaire et
d'accès aux droits
la lutte contre la fracture numérique et
nous avons aussi les activités
d'insertion ou gérons une centaine
d'ateliers chantier d'insertion ainsi
que des centres d'hébergement et de
résidences sociales la crise précédente
qui était celle de 2008 s'était traduite
pour les restos du coeur par l'arrivée
au bout de deux ans de 25% de personnes
en plus c'est une référence que nous
avons en permanence en tête et qui nous
inquiète puisque elle pourrait
préfigurer ce qui pourrait arriver à
l'issue de cette crise sociale qui suit
la cré de la crise sanitaire et
évidemment ça nous inquiète beaucoup et
j'y reviens sur les publics que nous
avons je crois qu'il est intéressant de
de donner quelques chiffres il ya deux
caractéristiques importantes dans les
publics qui sont reçus par les restos du
coeur c'est d'abord la jeunesse 40 % de
mineurs qui sont inscrits avec leurs
parents et puis 10 % de jeunes de 18 à
25 ans je le cite puisque c'est elle que
c'est un public qui est un peu au centre
des discussions politiques en ce moment
sur les aident à donner à ces jeunes
donc 10 points de jeunes entre 18 et 25
ans mais au total c'est une personne sur
deux inscrites aux restos du coeur
à moins de 26 ans
deuxième caractéristique celle isolement
des personnes que nous recevons la
moitié des familles que nous recevons
sont monoparentales
nous avons à peu près trois fois la
pourcentage le pourcentage qui existe
dans la population en général de deux
familles monoparentales c'est à dire 90
à 95% des cas des femmes seules avec
enfants et puis nous avons globalement
40 % de personnes seules donc
donc voilà un peu des caractéristiques
qui sont ils sont importantes pour
comprendre un peu le type d'action que
nous essayons de développer
alors maintenant l'impact de la crise
sanitaire sur sur ce fonctionnement
bien entendu comme tout le monde nous
avons été au mois de mars 2020
extrêmement perturbé et nous avons pu
continuer notre action moyennant un
certain nombre de mesures d'adaptation
qui sont des dégradation du service
rendu qui était pour nous indispensable
pour pouvoir continuer à fonctionner à
une époque où d'une part une partie des
bénévoles qui sont âgés s'était mis en
retrait et d'autre part comme tout le
monde nous n'avions pas de masse que
nous n'avions pas de gel hydroalcoolique
nous n'avions pas tout le matériel que
nous possédons aujourd'hui et donc on a
pu continuer à faire la distribution
alimentaire avec des méthodes on a
qualifié dans ce flot de drive c'est à
dire qu'avec des colis conformes sont
confectionnés à priori les gens
n'avaient plus le choix et repartir le
plus vite possible avec avec leurs colis
donc plus le choix
plus le temps de discuter plus d'accueil
qui est important pour prendre en compte
les problématiques des personnes qui
nous rejoignent
deuxième conséquence très ennuyeuse et
que nous avons cherché à compenser
progressivement
c'est l'arrêt de la plupart de ses
activités d'inclusion des dalles à
personne qu'il ne pouvait plus se
dérouler vous pouvez plus faire du
conseil à la soutient la recherche
d'emploi ou des cours de français par
exemple dans les conditions habituelles
et donc il a fallu les arrêter et toutes
nos tracts notre énergie est aujourd'hui
focalisés vers le redémarrage de ses
activités alors on a beaucoup parlé
pendant cette crise de l'arrivée de
nouveaux publics
c'est leur public au chiffre à peu près
à 15% des personnes qui viennent nous
rencontrer
on en a beaucoup parlé elle est gérante
y avait des petits boulots et cdd
intérim
les étudiants qui financer leurs études
avec des petits boulots notamment dans
la restauration qui sont arrêtés qui se
sont arrêtées brutalement on sans parler
des familles qui n'ont plus qui le
courant pré mettre leurs enfants à
l'école devait les nourrir à domicile ne
bénéficiait plus des cantines scolaires
qui qui ont en général des tarifs dits
sociaux vous voilà un petit peu là la
première première photo de les gens qui
sont arrivés chez nous avec dans
certains on a nous avons aussi des
activités de rue mais dans certaines
villes comme à paris à toulouse
il est très très forte augmentation de
la fréquentation de l'ot distribution
dans la rue qui ont été très brutal
alors aujourd'hui dans quelle situation
nous trouvons nous nous avons été nous
avons été aidés par les pouvoirs publics
par l'europe qui nous ont permis de
passer le capes capet aiguë de la crise
aujourd'hui nous projetant vers l'avenir
et ce qui nous inquiète c'est que
va-t-il se passer lorsque les aides
publiques aux entreprises vont s'arrêter
que va-t-il se passer quand la réforme
des indemnités chômage va rentrer en
ligne de but
tous ces éléments ne vont pas dans le
bon sens pour diminuer la fréquentation
des publics dans les files d'attentes
des restos du coeur et c'est cela qui
nous inquiète
est ce qu'on ne va pas avoir une brutale
augmentation du chômage qu'on n'a pas
encore complètement vu aujourd'hui qui
se traduira immédiatement par une
augmentation de la fréquence et de
fréquentation de nos centres de nos
centres d'activités donc vous voilà un
peu les inquiétudes avec en arrière-plan
cc 25% dont je parlais de d'augmentation
en 2008 et la crainte que nous avons
c'est évidemment que c'est 25% se
renouvelle alors peut-être un 1.6
l'unique ponctuelles veut compléter à la
fois sur les aides que nous avons eu du
talent de l'europe qui sont
intéressantes et qui pose question
éventuellement sur l'étude
vous menez sur les publics si elle veut
compléter un presque en avant parce que
je voudrais laisser du temps pour tout
le monde
tablant ce qui ressort effectivement de
ce qu'on a pu on peut commencer à
observer on a donc on a transmis à la
commission en amont de cette audition
cette étude flash qui était conduite en
fait juste après le premier confinement
est ce qui ressort au delà de la
dimension plantes stati des dunes et des
chiffres de fréquentation c'est vraiment
un phénomène l'aggravation de la
précarité c'est à dire de personnes qui
étaient déjà dans des situations de
précarité ou de quasi précarité qui avec
la crise son sens sur un phénomène un
processus de basculement qui n'est pas
immédiatement visible dans les chiffres
d'activité des associations mais qu'on
va très probablement voir dans l'est
dans les mois qui viennent c'est pour ça
que il mairie ont insisté aussi sur
scène la notion de crise qui sera
probablement durable et où la partie la
plus massive risque en fait d'arriver
d'arriver dans l'est dans les prochaines
années ça a été quelque part il ya 10
ans et ça risque d'être encore cette
fois-ci sur les aides de plus en détail
tout à perdre
il ya eu effectivement plusieurs aspects
il ya eu un plan d'urgence qui étaient
débloqués de manière assez assez
conséquente il ya un plan de relance qui
est en cours de mise en oeuvre
moi je pense que l'occasion d'y revenir
et puis il ya le soutien européen à
travers un programme spécifique qui
s'appelle le programme react a été
débloquée donc bénéficier aux quatre
associations qui mettent en oeuvre le
fades et c'est là l'une est qui et qui
est considérable et qui sera très utile
même si elle se met en oeuvre dans des
conditions qui sont pas totalement
satisfaisante de notre point de vue
puisque alors on est vraiment sur une
gamme très très dénudée deux promus mais
là encore je pense qu'on y reviendra
peut-être banlieue en les questions
réponses
très bien merci pour ses propos
liminaires peut-être monsieur yan auger
directeur général de l'association
nationale des épiceries solidaires
oui merci j'espère que vous m'entendez
bien parfait je vais tâcher d'être je
l'espère aussi complet que nos amis des
restos du coeur juste en quelques mois
sur le sur l'eau sur le périmètre donc
au sein de l'association landaise ou
fédère un réseau d'à peu près 400 vins
épicerie solidaire qui accompagne
environ deux cent mille personnes chaque
année et qui les accompagnent sous une
forme spécifique qui allie de l'aide
alimentaire et de l'accompagnement
social
là on retrouve quelque chose qui vient
d'être révoqué et qui je pense va
revenir dans toutes les présentations et
avec une aide alimentaire qu'il est
pratiqué sous une forme un petit peu
spécifique puisqu'il ya cette volonté de
le distribuer l'aide alimentaire sous la
forme d'établissements qui ressemble à
des commerces de proximité quelconque
à ceci près qu'ils sont dédiés à des
personnes bien sûr en situation de
précarité et au sein desquelles ces
personnes font leurs courses pour un
coût entre 10 et 30% de la valeur
marchande des produits comme ils le
feraient dans un commerce ordinaire mais
avec ce système de remises très
important qui leur donne accès à ses
produits pendant la fleur quelques mois
de présence au sein des épiceries
puisque ils sont censés ni être que de
passage pour quelques mois avant de
pouvoir retrouver une vie normale si je
puis dire bien sûr sur le terrain c'est
pas toujours aussi simple que ça pour
finir le petit panorama des activités et
en revenir au sujet du jour nous aussi
nous avons d'autres activités qui sont
au service ceux des premières puisque
nous avons également des chantiers
d'insertion qui livre en particulier des
fruits et légumes aux structures d'aidé
alimentaire aux épiceries du réseau en
baisse mais aussi à d'autres structures
ni conflit a parmi celles présentes
autour de la table aujourd'hui
voilà pour le panorama sur l'impact de
la crise et je vais pas être très
original en nous disant que depuis un an
ça a été par moment fort complexe
surtout lors du premier conseil mans où
c'était au tout début en tout cas un
joyeux bazar
petit à petit les choses se sont
structurées mais le mode de
fonctionnement dégradé est devenu
presque la normalité
ce qui n'est pas sans poser est
évidemment tout un tas de d'un tas de
problèmes et deux questions tout le
volet accompagnement social ateliers
collectifs etc
pour les bénéficiaires est très très
fragilisée par la part la situation donc
pour vous donner quelques quelques
grands chiffres allemands 2019 dans le
réseau des sons avait fait un peu plus
de 12000 ateliers à destination des
bénéficiaires
en 2020 on n'a fait que quatre mille
donc c'est pas si mal mais sachant qu'il
ya deux mois et demi du début de l'année
a qui ont fonctionné normalement et puis
ensuite sonné suivi ce que vous
connaissez donc voilà il n'y a pas lieu
de s'en étonner mais ce n'est pas une
très bonne nouvelle et ça nous inquiète
quant à notre capacité à accompagner les
personnes sur autre chose que de la
distribution alimentaire ce qui n'est
absolument pas la vocation des épiceries
solidaires sur la fréquentation
on a enregistré des hausses pas loin de
30 % en moyenne sur l'année 2020 avec
évidemment des pics très fort pendant
les coupes seulement et tout
particulièrement pendant les premiers où
on avait chiffré la hausse a à peu près
de 40% en moyenne
par contre ce qui est ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que dans ces moyennes
on retrouve des situations extrêmement
variables des structures qui n'ont
finalement presque pas connu
d'augmentation et d'autres qui font face
à des hausses de 100% ou de 150%
voilà ce qui est pas sans poser question
quant à leur capacité à absorber de
telles évolutions
donc ça c'est pour les pour les chiffres
globaux j'ai pas encore de visibilité
sur le sur sur le premier trimestre à
mais ça devrait venir assez vite et je
re de voir ça je pense que toutes les
associations sont autour de la table
sont amenés maintenant à faire si je me
dis pas de bêtises autres des
statistiques trimestrielles
sous l'impulsion de la dgcs de l'insee
et de la drees et je pense que ça va
nous aider à nous donner une vision de
la situation en cours de route sous une
forme que un peu formalisés standardisés
au delà des petites enquêtes qu'on peut
faire en interne ici ou là donc on verra
bien à sur les profils tu n'es pas grand
chose d'original à vous dire hélas on
retombe ce qu'il est ce qu'il ya déjà
été dit par les restos et ce qui va être
confirmée je pense par les confrères
beaucoup de personnes seules deux
personnes qui ont subi l'impact
économique de la crise soit de manière
ponctuelle parce que les magasins sont
fermés ou autre soit parce que on
commence à ressentir les impacts un peu
structurelles de la crise économique
dont beaucoup d'étudiants bien sûr
sachant qu'on a la particularité aussi
d'avoir des unités des épiceries qui
sont dédiées aux étudiants et qui sont
particulièrement touchées actuellement
et les familles monoparentales enfin bon
tout ce qui a été évoqué par les restos
la problématique des cantines scolaires
au printemps dernier et sans doute pour
les quelques semaines qui viennent ou
encore voilà c'est nous disait c'est pas
très original ce que je raconte mais je
crains que ça correspond parfaitement à
la réalité
nous aussi on a été aidé en 2020
particulier au travers des deux plans
d'urgence qui ont été mis en place pour
l'aide alimentaire de manière assez
rapide et significative il y a par
ailleurs excusé moi j'en prends de celle
de ce que je vais vous dire le plan de
relance on s'interroge beaucoup bien sûr
parce que
d'une part il ya énormément de demandes
formulées au travers de ce plan de
relance pour des projets sont donc très
intéressant mais ponctuelle et on
s'interroge beaucoup sur la pérennité
des moyens futur au delà des enveloppes
très significative mais ponctuelle qui
sont nés à disposition au travers de ce
plan de relance
donc il faut faire face de manière
relativement durable à une hausse de 30
% de la fréquentation
je ne sais pas bien comment tout ça va
s'organiser un autre toute petite
échelle le finalement parce que les
épiceries représente à peu près 5 6 % de
l'aide alimentaire
l'une de nos principales sources de
financement c'est le cnes le crédit
nationale des épiceries solidaires qui
permet de pallier le fait que les
épiceries n'ont pas accès aux achats des
puisqu'elle ne pratique pas l'aide
alimentaire gratuite en tout cas pas
majoritairement et bref cela ne se
connaissent et stable depuis plusieurs
années il l'est en tout cas entre 2020
et 2021 alors même que les besoins sont
en hausse de 30% au sein des épiceries
existantes et alors même que il s'ouvre
de nouvelles aux épiceries solidaires à
peu près toutes les semaines en ce
moment ben voilà donc on s'interroge
beaucoup quand c'est un exemple très
important se demande comment le cnes va
va pouvoir évoluer dans les années à
venir
au delà des belles démarche mais
ponctuelles menées au travers du plan de
relance
voilà j'espère ne pas avoir été trop
long mais on reviendra peut-être surtout
sans suite
c'est bon pour vous j'ai plus de gégé
plus de retours entre plus rien depuis
que j'ai causée
oh
non
mon oncle
en autant que lula ou la salade
voilà comment temps des mieux la 2 e
yvan très bon voilà c'est la présidente
qui avait le bois de simek avait oublié
d'appuyer sans micro monsieur nicolas
champion montant oui oui oui c'est bon
merci fait à longueur de journée des
petits soucis et écouter mais merci
beaucoup alors sur le panorama général
de secours populaire est de 1,8 million
de personnes dans plus de 1300 lieu
d'accueil du public répartis au travers
de l'ensemble du territoire français
alors on est une association
décentralisée ça veut dire qu'on a des
fédérations départementales et des
comités locaux ça nous permet d'être au
plus près de la population
évidemment ça nous a permis d'être au
plus près des gens pendant pendant cette
crise sanitaire sur sur les chiffres
généraux alors sur l'augmentation des
personnes avant avant la crise sanitaire
on est aidé en 2009 1 million 3 de
personnes
on est arrivé à un million huit en 2019
on avait déjà eu cinq cent mille
personnes en plus sur les dix dernières
années la typologie des publics alors on
a un chiffre presque similaire aux
courses entrée avec celui des
restaurants du coeur on a quarante deux
pour cent des personnes qui sont
accueillis au secours populaire et c'est
un chiffre qui est stable
quarante deux paires sont des personnes
avec lio skopia qui sont des enfants
donc via leurs parents en tout cas on a
42 % de mineurs
on a fait un sondage ipsos pour pour
parler de la crise en septembre dernier
et un français sur trois déjà en
septembre 2020 avait connu une baisse de
revenus pendant la crise sanitaire
donc ça donne à peu près l'idée de
l'ampleur de la vague de précarité à
laquelle on s'apprête à subir
alors évidemment je
je redis un peu déjà les les constats
qui ont été faits mais pendant la
première crise pendant le premier
confinement on a eu les populations qui
ont été précarisés très très vite qui
sont les personnes qui vivait de petits
boulots de missions d'intérim et qu'ils
soient arrivés rapidement chez nous
maintenant enfin depuis la rentrée
scolaire on a le public des étudiants et
on multiplie des antennes sur les campus
universitaires des solidaires et bus en
tout cas tout ce qui est dispositif pour
aller vers les publics là et on est on
est touché de plein fouet par une vague
de précarité étudiante
aussi est-ce qu'on peut noter c'est la
précarité psychologique dans laquelle se
trouvent les gens et se sont trouvés
très très vite ils soient arrivés chez
nous suite aux premiers confinement en
étant complètement désorientés ils ont
basculé très très brutalement dans la
précarité
et ça ça veut dire que quand ils sont
arrivés chez nous alors pareils endettés
en en organisation de distribution
alimentaire en bas d'un petit peu drive
en tout cas en conditions dégradées dans
toutes les histoires et laissez-nous
complètement déboussolé et on s'est
rendu compte qu'on a pu reprendre notre
travail d'accompagnement reprendre nos
permanences d'accueil social que ces
gens là vraiment on en avait marre
donc on a innové on a on a essayé de
continuer ce qu'on fait habituellement
qui est le droit aux vacances ont fait
des grandes journées des oubliés des
vacances
on les a multipliées ces journées là et
on a fait on a fait ce qu'on a appelé
des journées bonheur pour essayer
d'offrir une parenthèse un petit peu
pour que les gens puissent souffler
pendant l'été donc
donc voila un petit peu sur toutes nos
généralités après sur le sur les
perspectives alors le sondage express
qu'on a fait à nos fédérations récemment
laissent apparaître une augmentation de
30% des publics
on attend d'eux de bien consolider les
chiffres 2020 mais ça a l'air d'être la
tendance voilà on redoute un petit peu
là
d'inscription dans le temps cette
précarité les gens ont été aidés nous
aussi on a été aidé ça on peut le saluer
après l'état ou ponctuellement tout cas
sûr sur cette crise là malheureusement
on a peur que les gens se soient
s'arrête durablement dans la précarité
et que les financements un type
exceptionnel de perdure pas voilà je ne
vais pas rallonger le tableau sur les
points un peu plus spécifique je pense
que ça viendra dans les questions merci
à vous merci à vous monsieur fab à
thiais je vous laisse la parole donc
pour l'ordre de malte france on ne vous
entend pas merci vous entends par c'est
donc je parlerai de ce que c'est marc
derasse ans en france mais tout en
rappelant que nous sommes très présents
dans 26 pays et que nous avons des
actions alimentaire en afrique de
l'ouest dans les saunas indien et dans
un certain nombre d'autres d'autres
zones des précarités parfois similaires
par sont très différentes
jade est vrai également que notre
tradition est une tradition sanitaire et
sociale dans nos internautes le fragile
dans le domaine de la santé et dans le
domaine de l'accompagnement social y
compris alimentaires
donc c'est important parce que ça guide
un peu la manière dont on a lu la crise
et thomas et dont on a adapté les
dispositifs que nous avons déjà repéré
en cinq ans france
alors nous avons dix établissements
médico-sociaux 110 délégation douze
mille bénévoles nous avons distribuables
après 168 il repart l'année dernière
donc on n'a pas long
l'autre grande association mais on a une
spécificité je dirai qui et
d'intervenants dans la rue et à partir
de la rue c'est à dire dans le dernier
maillon que ce soit sous forme de petits
déjeuners de maroun alimentaire de
maraude mobile de dispensaires et deux
péniches
on est plutôt sur la fée karité qui
arrive dans la rue j'ai bien sûr comme
tout le monde je crois que le coc vie de
nos on avait des actions alimentaire à
côté des actions sociales et médicales
qui était relativement résiduelles 10 à
20 % de l activité avec un kobe dont un
tout basculer sauf le secouriste en
intégrant la dimension alimentaire entre
spécifiques avec des maraudes spécial ou
avec un dispositif qu'on a créé est un
dispositif global sanitaires et sociales
et d'hygiène
il s'appelle sony mars mais je
reviendrai ça a été notre innovation
majeure l'année iranienne dans la
bascule un peu près 60% de nos activités
en avec distributions alimentaires sur
les publics
naturellement passant le dernier jeu fut
le cas vendredi ce qui a été dit je
voudrais rajouter deux catégories
étaient le boom a évoqué le premier
c'est vrai on commence à voir arriver
les seniors entrée caire dans nos cordes
alimentaire au bout mais ça commence et
c'est paraît-il lioration un énorme choc
ne précarité qui va nous rendre en
disant qu'il arrivait lui laissant la
population dans leur article brecker à
titre d'exemple nous avons un ipad à
saint-etienne 10 à 100 % grâce à l'aide
sociale
aujourd'hui nous avons un dossier
d'admission sur deux qui est issu d'un
personnes en très grande précarité
ce que nous appelons nous les ibères
précaire c'est à dire la personne n'a
pas de ressources et safari n'en a pas
non plus par ailleurs nous sommes en
train de réfléchir dans cars 2 me
entre nouvelles stratégies à l'accueil
en établissement de ces personnes qui
n'ont dans l'instant par les moyens de
vieillir nière domicile n'est ni en
établissement et est très mal dans l'âge
et puis l'autre catégorie quelques une
tendance lourde sans doute le candidat
accéléré je ne suis pas certain et qui
n'arrivait pas de 2,2 grâce et à
l'intérieur de la tuque ont sans tâche
de régulation dit au seuil de pauvreté
et encore il faudrait qu'on réalise le
salaire médian qui devance de calcul
or avoir des chiffres plus correct c'est
le développement de personnes qui sont
en situation d'extrême précarité sert de
champ qui sont quasiment invisibles
on ne voit plus apparaître dans les
zones d'urgence de rue dans les unités
mobiles qu'il faut aller chercher
souvent envoyés par des associations
trans des associations de proximité des
voisins père est le véhicule il me dit
si tu y vas y a quelqu'un qui vit dans
une barre d'immeuble mais vous ne verrez
jamais dans la rue et il n'a même plus
tenir et les ressources pour aller dans
ces systèmes d'urgence donc à
l'intérieur de la notion de pauvreté
il faut voir comment on définit les
termes à lebon le mouvement n'a rien et
le break et rats peuvent et le très
fragile comme disait le sociologue
rostand elle est la personne la plus
fragile alpha de marien et à la peur là
on a une frange du père treguer qui est
assez importante on ne sait pas
l'évacuer qui nous ne sommes pas
représentatifs pour faire des analyses
macroéconomiques mais mais en coop en
senior 3 300 mille quatre cent mille
personnes se sont elles gspr la
fondation abbé pierre je ne sais pas
mais c'est le parent grandi évidemment
on a vu arriver le million de personnes
les dernières des classiques du
quotidien souvent des familles isolées
on a vu apparaître avec les problèmes de
par les problèmes alimentaires sont des
gens on a vu se nourrir de voir un
ghetto belle avec une très faible
culture d'urgence un sentiment
d'effondrement psychologique très dur et
est assez peu d'informations au départ
sur vous allez trouver un poste les
restos du coeur de ce groupe populaire
quand on va celle d'omar wade
et puis le phénomène des jeunes auxquels
mandat on a naturellement
normalement si c'est les châssis stars
et moi sur deux publics complémentaires
que nous rencontrons plus parce que ans
dans la rue c'est risible et précaires
selon mais en gros depuis longtemps et
puis des tout nouveaux qui sont des
indices de l'arrivée de personnes de 70
ans 65 ans 70 ans parfois dans les
maraudes alimentaires ou les centres de
distributions fixes alors le coc vie de
quelqu'un n'a été généré l'arabe du
comité non à toute fuite dans la lignée
ce qui a été dit sur le fait que
l'alimentation révèle beaucoup d'autres
besoins psychologiques notamment mais
également sanitaires le premier souci ça
a été de trouver les réponses de rue qui
offrait une solution globale donc on va
lancer un nouveau type de mao zedong
solinas on en a 25 et on va les étant
très considérablement qui sont des
unités mobiles dans lequel il ya un
professionnel de santé
il fait des soins de premier recours une
distribution alimentaire une
distribution et les conseils d'hygiène
masculin et féminin
il me fait un accompagnement social qui
aujourd'hui et réduire ce que ça sert
nommer les vols mais en cherche à
développer en partenariat avec les
collectivités locales et dans
institutions le faire de pouvoir
embarquer des travailleurs sociaux dans
ces unités mobiles pour faire des
diagnostics de connaissances et l'état
des droits de ces personnes fragiles
sont très éloignés de toute structure
institutionnelle
l'idée d'un tel système la ruine à
personne parce que plus les précaires -
elle va aller dans le système et c'est
vraiment une de nos grandes
préoccupations à cinq ans c'est
d'organiser la rue comme un véritable
système sanitaire et social avec les
réponses pérennes et pas des réponses
exceptionnelles d'urgence
ça c'est le changement à notre avis qu
induit une évolution quantitative et
qualitative de la précarité
nous en avons bénéficié d'aucune aime
pas un centime de la commission
européenne en est en appel d'offres
actuellement sur france relance on est
une douzaine d'épiceries solidaires dans
ces 10 moyenne tous seuls comme des
grands en plus d'un an sans toucher un
centime de quelques font d'elle que ce
soit ils sont jamais arrivés jusqu'à
nous alors on n'est pas référencé parmi
les grandes associations n'étaient pas
suffisamment en veille
enfin en tout cas tant de cession de 100
km ou d'interlocuteurs collectivités
locales ont même été amenés à intervenir
pour le compte d'autres associations
spécialisées en distribution des
menteurs comme la banque alimentaire
dans les bénévoles a été en partie plus
est chez une autre
on a la chance d'avoir un bénévolat avec
un ventre médian plutôt jeunes enfants
tout cas en dessous des les granges
lascaux vide ce qui nous a permis nos
sincères dont deux départements de la
gironde partenaires de compléter de
distribuer là où d'autres associations
s'arrêter mais en à fonctionner sur des
dons privés les noms d'entreprises des
dons de certaines collectivités locales
wimbée non public mais très résiduel
mais on a complètement échappé aux on
était hors dispositifs belles dents dit
il n'arrivait pas jusqu'à nous voilà
troisièmement sur l'impact du vide c'est
sûr qu'on a vu la fermeture le centre de
distribution fixe notamment aux communes
a mis dans la rue dans un état de faim
les tas de gens qui avaient une
inquiétude très clair mais qui avait
l'habitude de trouver des points fixes
de distribution institutionnels et là
c'est un gigantesque conjure bord nous
c'est qu'on peut une personne peut se
loger dans la rue mais il faut quand
même quelle façon sera fera par jour
et la question est que certains d'autres
que d'autres associations roman 21 est
une question cruciale
cc c'est la question déjà sur la base
nutritionnelle
on parle de la qualité nutritionnelle
c'est d'arriver à avoir une continuité
une coordination entre associations pour
arriver à faire le nom d' or tant
attendu par jour on s'est retrouvé du
point de vue de la coordination et des
situations très baroque des ombres
blanches territoriales les quartiers les
cantons ou des bassins de vie au sens
des ars où irais pas de distribution
alimentaire et bien longtemps j'ai fait
beaucoup de maraude à l'alimentaire à
paris des endroits où on était avec le
parce que je sais pas comment fonctionne
et la régulation du 115 je me souviens
de rue de rivoli de la protection civile
qui dit serait descendre ici dans notre
cas nous mène au milieu et derrière le
service social qui distribuaient des
sandwiches en argenté et les rue de
rivoli avec des gens qui croulait sous
les 100 briques
donc là on est à voir au delà du fait
qu'on peut pas habiter la personne en
train de descendre
on avait un problème de coordination a
même s'envole tout cas dans la métropole
parisienne et je vais servir très
souvent ce phénomène voilà ce que je
voulais dire très très rapidement on
développe
voilà on cherche à trouver des
architectures en partenariat avec les
autres associations localement qui
permettent de couvrir le très avancé ce
qui est une réponse madeline
l'orientation vers une épicerie où un
centre de distribution fixe et puis
après leurs légumes et riz au plan
sanitaire assiko logique ou voir un
terme de logement et aimé s'est affûté
que turlan sont en asie et qui nécessite
beaucoup de coordination je pense que
les collectivités locales sont la
cheville ouvrière mascalzone la maille
de leur proximité et la connaissance du
tissu associatif
mais cette crs avec l'appui des
directions de la cohésion de solidarité
devrait être le maillon de demain qui
l'amène monter ses affréteurs on a une
architecture en construction aujourd'hui
la mairie de toulon les associations de
manière à créer ces niveaux à présent
chat
voilà travaillement merci
merci à vous monsieur claude ballon pour
la fédération française des banques
alimentaires
oui bonjour à tous j'ai déjà vous
présenter barbara mauvillain qui est la
directrice des relations
institutionnelles de la fédération des
banques alimentaires et qui a rédigé une
longue note 13 pages bon je me suis
évidemment inspiré et qui pourra vous
être renvoyés si vous en exprimé le
besoin
quatre idées la première c'est que le
réseau des 79 banques alimentaires est
un outil de redit séderie sion j'allais
dire à bon compte pour l'état petit 2 le
confinement accru les besoins de l'aide
alimentaire
troisièmement l'aide alimentaire a été
bien soutenue et bien coordonnée par les
pouvoirs publics au sens large
et quatrièmement je terminerai par des
pistes des sujets sont deux solutions au
nom de six ou sept
d'abord un bref rappel sur le réseau des
79 banques alimentaires qui avec les
annexes et les antennes fonds en 108
établissements physique donc qui
couvrent vraiment toute la france et ce
réseau assure 39 % de l'aide alimentaire
en france
jusqu'à présent les banques alimentaires
enfin jusqu'au premier confinement les
banques alimentaires ne redistribue est
pas ne distribuez pas aux bénéficiaires
finaux
mr distribuer cette aide alimentaire à
6011 association composée de ccs
d'épicerie sociale et d'autres
associations
on a redistribué en 2020 sans 3681
tonnes sans 3681 tonnes à 2,1 millions
de bénéficiaires soit 224 millions de
repas concrètement ça fait 40,3 kg par
bénéficiaire final et non pas par
association soit l'équivalent de 96
euros par mois ce équivaut à une aide de
16 euros par mois et quand j'ai dit que
c'était une délégation de service public
finalement qui rit beaucoup à moindre
coût parce que le réseau coûte 35
millions d'euros par an avec les
salaires d'essence 567 bénévoles les
frais de location de certains entrepôts
et certains établissements les camions
la réparation et c'est donc 35 millions
de coûts pour redistribuer une valeur
alimentaire de 442 millions puisque nous
redistribuons principalement avec des
bénévoles et on redistribuait j'allais
dire majoritairement des produits qu'on
nous donnait est justement le coc vie de
la cog hill a fait évoluer ses grands
principes fondateurs des banques
alimentaires
la deuxième idée c'est que la crise
sanitaire et le premier confinement on a
cru évidemment comme ça a déjà été dit
par les collègues
la demande d'aidé alimentaire alors de
deux éléments statistiques j'allais dire
de mars à fin juin et après pour toute
l'année parce que vous allez voir c'est
différent
de mars à juin le volume distribué
augmenté de 20%
et c'est à peu près équivalent puisque
les stocks ont diminué de 22%
il y a une assez forte augmentation
d'associations partenaires et qui on
remet cette aide alimentaire puisque
nous sommes passés de 5400 à 6011 alors
le supplément cd crous des associations
étudiants et des associations qui se
sont créés à l'occasion de la coved
surtout dans les grandes métropoles et
dont une partie a subsisté donc
actuellement nous remettons à 6011
association ça se décompose par 48,5 %
d'associations indépendant 26 3% de
grand réseau caritatif et les ccs 25,2
pour cent
si on regarde maintenant sur la totalité
de l'année la totalité de l'année le
nombre de bénéficiaires a augmenté de 6%
et le volume distribué diminué de 1%
quels sont les nouveaux publics ça a été
déjà dit par les collègues les
travailleurs précaires au noir les
auto-entrepreneurs 35% des personnes
aidées ont déclaré avoir cours
alimentaires depuis moins de six mois
c'est ce qu'il trouve c'est des gens qui
étaient au chômage de fait beaucoup de
sans abri et des cons d'immigrés
deuxièmement ça a été aussi évoqué les
familles qui ne bénéficiaient pas de
l'aide de la comptine scolaires à bas
coût et eu par exemple un afflux de
perse de famille de marseille nord
auprès de la bea de marseille
et troisièmement les étudiants ça a été
une façon pour nous de rompre la
tradition qu'on ne remet tait pas
directement bénéficiaires finaux puisque
la région nouvelle aquitaine et la
région occitanie nous ont demandé de
redistribuer des colis de distribuer des
colis des paniers aux étudiants ce qui a
été fait puisque on a distribué entre
autres 22 1130 colis pendant le premier
confinement est maintenant près de la
moitié des banques alimentaires
continuent à servir des associations
étudiants et 23 banques alimentaires ont
créé des associations des épiceries
solidaires mais en partenarait steen aux
étudiants mais en partenariat avec
d'autres associations ou des
départements ou en dess par exemple où
la croix rouge et ces jeux là je vais
vous lire les résultats statistiques
alors maintenant qu'elle est la
population à qui on remet tait l'aide
alimentaire entre septembre 30 septembre
2000 devin et le 10 novembre sur les
résultats de statistiques qui sont
remontés donc les personnes avec 48 ans
en moyenne 70 % étaient des femmes 30%
étaient des familles monoparentales
mais contrairement
peut-être à ce qu'on pouvait attendre
qu'à 85 % des personnes venant à l'aide
alimentaire ont un logement plus d'un
quart sont des chômeurs 70% ont qui ont
un travail long on t'a travail à temps
partiel
évidemment ces personnes ont des
ressources financières limitées
71 % disposent de moins de 1000 euros
par mois les bénéficiaires déclare
économiser 92 euros en moyenne grâce à
l'aide alimentaire et les personnes
aidées donc entre le 30 septembre et les
10 novembre avaient un revenu moyen de
839 euros
la troisième idée c'est que l'aide
alimentaire a été bien coordonnée et
très bien soutenu par les pouvoirs
publics
d'abord les soutiens financiers ça a
déjà été dit si on contracte si on
accumule les deux grandes catégories de
crédits européens les crédits du
programme et les crédits exceptionnels
sa fédé plus car + 48 % l'état français
nous a versé 3 subvention exceptionnelle
ap les subventions que vite pour un
total de 4 millions neuf cent quarante
huit mille 785 euros il y a eu aussi au
niveau des départements ou des régions
des subventions des préfectures des
subventions des collectivités locales
que ça soit région département et mairie
par exemple la région nouvelle aquitaine
pour qu'on distribue aux étudiants 3400
euros la région aura trois cent mille
euros la région de haute france 224 1832
euros sans compter la bretagne
l'occitanie paca et ses plus de nombreux
départements plus de nombreuses mairies
soit sous forme de subventions de prêts
de locaux de près d'entrepôts et même de
mise à disposition pendant le premier
confinement d'agents municipaux comme à
poitiers ou strasbourg
ou d'agents des ccs mise à disposition
pour pallier l'effondrement du nombre de
bénévoles puisque 65% nos bénévoles ont
plus de 65 ans et on leur a demandé de
rester chez eux
vu les risques qu'ils encouraient donc
vraiment nous avons bénéficié d'un
faisceau de solidarité y compris venant
de l'industrie agroalimentaire et des
coopératives agricoles puisque le volume
des dons provenant des industries
agroalimentaires et des coopératives
agricoles a augmenté de 32% au cours
donc entre mars et la fin juin 2000 par
la quatrième idée
ce sont des pistes d'amélioration des
suggestions d'amélioration d'abord la
première c'est remédier à la baisse
tendancielle et brutale de la ramasse la
ramasser ce que les banques alimentaires
et beaucoup de collègues vont chercher
tous les matins derrière carrefour enfin
d'autres derrière les entrepôts de
carrefour aux grands frais auchan
leclerc etc
et cette baisse est hamas qui avait déjà
commencé à baisser avant même la crise
de qu'ovide baisse maintenant
brutalement entre mars canton quantifie
ce qu'on a reçu de la ramasse en mars
2020 par rapport à mars 2010neuf
s'abaisser de -32%
quant aux quantifie le produit de la
ramasse d'avril 2020 par rapport à avril
2019 s'abaisser de -47%
et cette baisse continue encore
aujourd'hui de manière inquiétante
exemple j'ai appelé le président de la
béate bordeaux aujourd'hui en une année
le tonnage de la ramasse est passé de
3000 tonnes en 2010 9 à 2000 tonnes en
2000 va ça vient pour les raisons sont
bien connus meilleure gestion des stocks
les grandes et moyennes surfaces ont
toutes ouvert dès des solderies avec eux
des produits en limite de péremption ça
vient aussi de la concurrence que
j'appelle légitime parce que
c'est fini les monopoles d'autres
associations ou d'autres démarches
donc il faudra qu'on réfléchisse parce
que cet effondrement des dons des
grandes et moyennes surfaces accentue
l'institutionnalisation des dons c'est à
dire que la tradition des banques
alimentaires jusqu'en 2019 c'est qu'on
distribuait 100 % de produits qu'on nous
avait donné et au moment où on se parle
on redistribue 77% de produits qu'on
nous a donnée le reste les 23 pour cent
c'est les fonds européens les
subventions de l'état les subventions
des mairies les départements les régions
et les préfectures de département
donc il va ça change vraiment la nature
de nos approvisionnements
cet effondrement de ce que nous donne
tous les matins les grandes et moyennes
surfaces ça c'est la première suggestion
la deuxième suggestion c'est qu'on
voudrait bien que soit simplifiée et
assouplit la procédure des marchés
publics
lancé par france agrimer pour utiliser
les fonds européens
il ya eu cinq appels d'offres lancé par
france agrimer en 2020 qui se sont
avérés infructueux par exemple le marché
du lait par exemple le marché de l'huile
ce qui fait que il ya eu un manque de
duy les un manque de lait dans de
nombreuses banques alimentaires et
deuxième conséquence de cette lourdeur
les livraisons se sont effectués avec
retard
70% des aliments achetés avec les fonds
européens 2020 ont été livrés en 2021
toujours au sujet de l'utilisation des
fonds européens
on voudrait on redevienne à plus de
diversité dans les produits que l'on
peut acheter avec les fonds européens
avant nous pouvions acheter 45 produits
et maintenant on ne peut plus en acheter
que 38 kg est insuffisant surtout que se
font surtout évidemment des produits
secs la troisième
gestion c'est que concerne france
relance il ya beaucoup de banques
alimentaires qui ont déposé des dossiers
mais qui comptait encore déposé des
dossiers pour bénéficier des 100
millions accordés sur le flou on se
lance pour la modernisation des
associations et on a récemment appris
qu'il y avait tellement de dossiers
déposés la sélection allait se faire
lors de la première distribution qu'il
n'y aurait pas de distribuer d'autres
distributions et que les 100 millions
d'euros à l'aide consommer pour les
dossiers certains dossiers qui avaient
déjà été déposées or de nombreuses
banques alimentaires avaient déposé des
dossiers pour créer des ateliers de
transformation des aliments
d'amélioration des aliments et aussi
pour créer des épiceries sociales pour
les étudiants tout aussi je vais y
revenir d'initier des réseaux de
distribution milieu rural et je note
d'ailleurs c'est révélateur que personne
n'en a parlé c'est pas si la dire mais
c'est un gros manque en france une
grande insuffisante la troisième idée la
quatrième idée c'est de profiter de
l'aide alimentaire pour délivrer de
l'accompagnement social ça c'est une
orientation que s'impose maintenant la
banque alimentaire
nous avons fait un sondage en décembre
2020 avec la l'institut de sondages csa
et 66 % des bénéficiaires disent avoir
besoin d'un accompagnement social des
bénéficiaires de l'aide alimentaire
évidemment 84 % des plus de 70 ans
disent avoir besoin d'un accompagnement
social
j'y reviendrai c'est un des risques du
chèque alimentaire elle qu'il est
instruit actuellement de constituer une
aide alimentaire directe qui
amoindrirait qui court circuiterait
l'accompagnement social et à mon avis
c'est pas moi de parler pour les autres
mais ça ça concerne tous les grands
réseaux qui sont ici présents et qu'il
faut aussi beaucoup plus que nous de
l'accompagnement social donc déjà au
sein des banques alimentaires nous
souhaitons après la fin de la crise
sanitaire reprendre nos actions
d'accompagnement ça veut dire
concrètement les ateliers sur la lutte
anti gaspillage puisque la la lutte anti
gaspillage est le deuxième grand
objectif du réseau des banques
alimentaires reprend les ateliers santé
reprend des ateliers cuisine avec des
bus itinérant qui fonctionnait comme en
gironde pour apprendre aux personnes à
tirer parti des produits qu'on leur
donne nous souhaitons aussi ce qu'on a
initié de force pendant la coved
développer la la délivrance directe des
produits bénéficiaires finaux
c'est le cas des étudiants parce qu'on
s'a mellick on s'aperçoit que c'est une
bonne façon de leur accompagné de la
raccorder de l'accompagnement social et
lutter contre leur solitude
concrètement ça veut dire que beaucoup
d'étudiants à qui on a distribué des
paniers des colis ont renvoyé
l'ascenseur en venant dans gb a entre
autres pour organiser la grande collecte
nationale des 27 28 29 novembre la
quatrième la cinquième fils s'est
développée l'aide alimentaire en milieu
rural c'est facile à dire c'est
extrêmement difficile à faire on a déjà
quelques initiatives comme dans le
morbihan où la banque alimentaire grâce
à une subvention de l'état et du
département s'est acheté un 1/4 et
fournit la banque alimentaire fournit à
la croix rouge
les aliments que la croix rouge
distribue au sein des chefs lieux de
canton du morbihan est actuellement dans
la nièvre département mon département
d'origine
nous sommes en train de détecter des
zones blanches pour voir comment
concrètement on peut lancer une
distribution itinérante de l'aide
alimentaire
la 5ème idée c'est améliorer la qualité
nutritionnelle des aliments distribués
quand on regarde le panel des aliments
qu distribuer les les banques
alimentaires en gros pour aller vite il
ya trop de féculents ya trop de sucre
par rapport il ya trop de peau
cuisiné par rapport aux normes
nutritionnels recommandés
il n'y a pas assez de gens n'y a pas
assez de fruits il n'y a pas assez de
légumes
c'est pourquoi les banques alimentaires
sont candidates pour participer au
nouveau dispositif du chèque aliments de
façon concrète
d'abord recevoir une partie d'échecs
alimentaire pour distribuer en même
temps qu'elle distribue des produits
secs comme appoint pour que la personne
à qui on donne ou les associations à qui
on donne ses produits secs puisse
acheter des compléments de produits
frais principalement fruits et légumes
et viandes et bénéficier deuxième façon
des chèques alimentaires pourraient
obliger d'acheter aux agriculteurs
locaux
avec donc une obligation d'acheter aux
agriculteurs et aux éleveurs locaux
c'est faisable puisque nous le faisons
déjà puisque ça a été accrue pendant le
premier confinement grâce à
l'instigation de certaines régions par
régions nouvelle aquitaine par exemple
nous a donné des crédits à condition
qu'on consomme au minimum 25 % des
crédits par des achats aux agriculteurs
locaux l'aide de la région occitanie
était un peu différente parce que c'est
la région occitanie qui a acheté
elle-même aux éleveurs et aux
agriculteurs locaux pour nous redonner
aux banques alimentaires les aliments à
à redistribuer la banque alimentaire de
saint lô doit utiliser les subventions
du département pour acheter les produits
régionaux etc
les pyrénées orientales de plus en plus
de banques alimentaires achète
localement pour améliorer la qualité des
aliments distribués et dernier dernière
suggestion c'est que nous pourrions même
si des coopérations existent déjà à
croître approfondir les articulations
entre tous les grands réseaux
distributeurs ça existe mais c'est
inégal ce nom un département et tout en
respectant leur histoire leur
personnalité leur individualité leur
spécialité spécificité je pense qu'on
peut faire mieux en matière
d'articulation et de coopération
mesdames et messieurs ce que je voulais
vous proposer merci à pour mais chez
balland et merci à vous 5
ou cinq associations pour ses propos
liminaires sans plus tarder je laisse la
parole à balad là à porter et directrice
a interrogé précisé sur certaines
questions merci à la présidente et merci
à vous toutes et tous de votre
intervention
alors j'avoue que je ne m'étais beaucoup
de choses j'espère me retrouver dans
tout ce que je vais je vais vous énoncez
et peut-être point sur lequel on attend
un certain nombre de précisions
d'abord vous remercier vous
individuellement mais au delà les
équipes que vous représentez parce que
je crois que les personnes qui
fréquentent les établissements cause est
présenté les associations vous avez
présenté les points que vous présentez
sont toutes des personnes qui finalement
ont tout perdu y compris parfois la
dignité
puisque quand on frappe à vos portes
c'est je crois parce qu'on a fait le
tour de tous y compris des solutions de
proximité et qu'on ne trouve rien avant
de revenir justement sur ces publics ce
qui est assez paradoxal finalement c'est
que durant cette crise sanitaire lors
même si un vous l'avez vue sur la
question hier ne nous arrêtons pas
spécifiquement à cette crise sanitaire
enfin elle est quand même dans les
esprits des uns et des autres nous avons
eu quand même si cette crise sanitaire
un déploiement de dispositifs des
mesures est gelée dire j'utilise ce
terme à dessein qui avait pour vocation
d'embrasser toutes les situations y
compris des personnes qui étaient des
personnes demandeurs d'emploi qui était
en difficulté y compris des personnes
qui n'entrait pas dans les radars je
pense notamment aux familles qui avaient
des enfants qui fréquentaient les
cantines scolaires on aurait jamais pu
penser qu'il fallait effectivement à les
compenser le coût des cantines scolaires
et ça a été fait et finalement avec des
dispositifs qui sont adaptés on constate
quand même une augmentation du nombre de
personnes qui fréquentent les structures
alimentaire donc comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer est-ce que nous sommes sur
des enjeux de recours au droit ou est-ce
que nous sommes sur finalement des
personnes qui échappent aux dispositifs
et j'avais dire
au service classique que nous n'aurions
pas forcément vu et qui du coup se
retrouvent à vos portes aujourd'hui de
la même façon vous avez parler les uns
les autres services ont beau public de
public parfois pauvres depuis que
parfois précaire de public hyper
précaires ou de grande pauvreté
hier vous avez utilisé des termes qui
sont un peu différenciés est ce que vous
êtes aligné sur cette terminologie est
ce qu'il y a besoin effectivement de
préciser un certain nombre de choses
pour savoir de quel public qu'on peut
parler parce que finalement on
s'aperçoit quand même qu'on a beaucoup
de mal à évaluer dans notre pays
à l'instant t notamment les publics
précaires qui sont les pluies qui nous
intéresse dans cette mission
d'information pour éviter qu'ils
sombrent dans la pauvreté
et est ce que vous êtes vous n'êtes pas
au final un thermomètre soit des publics
qui sont finalement des publics pauvres
et finalement un thermomètre de nos
politiques préventives qui ont échoué
ou alors des publics qui sont encore des
publics précaires et sur lequel nous
pourrions intervenir et dans ce cas là
dans ce cas là nous aurions besoin de
remonter peut-être s'agissant de vos
institutions de remontée d'informations
plus précises
peut-être un peu plus régulière même si
je sais que d'après les administratifs
c'est un peu lourd pour qu'on essaye de
pallier cet enjeu de passage de la
précarité à la pauvreté
vous avez évoqué les uns les autres en
termes de moyens que telle situation un
peu différente
monsieur ballan vous avez expliqué que
finalement vous aviez été au rendez-vous
de dz
j'ai entendu le président de l'ordre de
masse monsieur fava tiédir qu'il n'avait
pas du tout une aide de l'état
donc finalement est ce que vous êtes en
capacité d'évaluer les montants qui
seraient nécessaires aujourd'hui
étant entendu que j'ai bien entendu que
tout où nos tier que votre inquiétude
face à la fin des face à la fin des
dispositifs de soutien à l'emploi et
avec la crainte éventuellement de voir
arriver des publics nouveaux mais
arrêtons-nous j'allais d'hier à
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il ya effectivement des
besoins qui ne seraient pas couverts
aujourd'hui avec l'augmentation des
publics que vous avez eu enfin
s'agissant effectivement des enjeux
territoriaux
vous avez évoqué monsieur ballan la
ruralité alors c'est vrai que ça nous
intéresse mais pour autant j'ai beaucoup
entendu d'intervention sont les grandes
villes sur peut-être les métropoles
classique paris lyon marseille
est-ce que la précarité la pauvreté
touche davantage c'est population là où
vous êtes en règle générale présent et
du coup vous pouvez mieux les mesurer ou
est-ce qu'au final il y à une pauvreté
qu'on ne voit pas en milieu rural et
qu'on ne peut pas mesurer parce que
finalement le maillage je n'ai pas dire
qu'il est inexistant parce que je pense
que quand même de très fortes
mobilisations rural mais en tout cas il
est moins et moi présent et moins
prégnant qu'est ce que ce qui ne
pourrait être en milieu urbain voilà sur
ses premières questions peut-être un peu
transversale qui veut commencer les
restos du coeur merrion oui peut-être
deux ou trois deux ou trois éléments que
qui pourra compléter également sûr
d'avoir ce que vous évoquez sur conduire
les personnes qui ont été fragilisés par
un par le groupement pour nous ce
n'était pas vraiment une surprise
intérêts notamment sur la fermeture des
cantines scolaires
on s'arrange on a d'ailleurs alerté dès
les débuts du confinement là dessus et
avant même d'ailleurs la fermeture des
établissements parce que on avait déjà
l'expérience ça parce que on avait déjà
notée dans le monde normal que lorsque
les cantines scolaires étaient fermés ou
les enfants n'y allez pas notamment le
mercredi on notait déjà une augmentation
de ces publics sur nos activités de
distribution à la rue donc en fait
c'était ça faisait partie des alertes
qu'on apporte et qu'on a porté très peu
et c'est vrai que ce qui s'est passé
avec la crise c'est beaucoup encore une
fois une fragilisation de personnes
comptait déjà en précarité et qui se
sont retrouvés sans rien donc c'est le
cas de ces pionniers c'est le cas de
travailleurs précaires c'est le cas d'
indépendants aussi qu'ils sont retrouvés
sans rien des étudiants dont on parle
beaucoup ces temps ci c'est à dire à
tous que là dessus c'est vrai que c'est
c'est pour l'instant la partie
simplement merger de l'iceberg
on va dire qu'on perçoit mais il
voir certainement quelque chose de plus
massif en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
redoute dans les prochaines années sur
les remontées de données pour vous
répondre très vite on est en train
d'avancer beaucoup c'est ce que disait
il ya danger je crois avec l'adresse
l'insee la dgcs disque en a maintenant
des volontés données qui sont
trimestriels qu'on a eu voilà ces
derniers temps énormément de
sollicitations
ce volet là donc la statistique publique
en tout cas a pris ce cet aspect là on
comptait il devrait y avoir d'à priori
des publications plus régulière là
dessus et sur les bons sur les aident
effectivement on a reçu des aides qui
sont ponctuels qui sont importantes pour
cette année mais encore une fois on sait
parce que voilà de quoi de quoi sera
fait sera fait demain les difficultés
qu'on a eu c'est c'est parfois des
difficultés de mise en oeuvre de c est
de là que ce soit sur le plan d'urgence
c'était des aides en fait très
décentralisée et ont créé des
complexités à c'est assez incroyable
dans la mise en oeuvre même si au final
on a quand même été bien aidés mais dans
des conditions un peu difficiles sur le
plan de relance je crois que c'est plein
de ballons qui en a parlé il faut la
décision a été prise de débloquer
l'intégralité de nos enveloppes en un
appel à projet et non deux appels à
projets donc là dessus de notre point de
vue c'est une décision sur laquelle il
faut il faut revenir et puis da
peut-être un sujet aussi sûr qu'on n'a
pas évoqué et qui là aussi est
nécessaire c'est sur la question des
locaux puisque voilà dans l'ue parle de
crise sanitaire et en particulier sur
n'a plus qu'un cueillir on a besoin
d'avoir des locaux qu'ils soient adaptés
à l'accueil de ces personnes et
aujourd'hui ça fait partie des très
lourd de difficulté qu'on peut qu'on
peut qu'on peut avoir enfin je dis
simplement un mot puisque c'est une
initiative du sénat qui a été prise à
l'initiative des sénateurs retailleau et
et ferro il y à il ya un an
c'est que là beaucoup d'associations et
en particulier les restos repose
beaucoup sur la générosité du public
puisque c'est la majorité de notre
financement qui vient des donateurs
privés
il ya eu une décision de du sénat quand
cas une proposition du sénat qui a été
voté de faire passer la loi coluche le
plafond de la loi coluche de 500 et
quelques rois 1000 euros c'est une
disposition qui était valable pour 2020
et pour 2021
mais ensuite voilà pour l'instant on n'a
pas de certitudes sur l'avenir et
il n'y a pas de prolongation de ce
dispositif là on retombera sur un
plafond qui encouragera pas autant la
générosité alors je pense que on en aura
certainement besoin aussi en 2020 peut
être complétée sur un sujet qui a été
donc trois sujets qui ont été évoqués
vous avez parlé madame du non recours au
droit qui est effectivement un sujet qui
nous préoccupe beaucoup et qui rend
d'autant plus problématique le fait que
nous ayons des difficultés pour
poursuivre nos activités
d'accompagnement des personnes qui
veulent nous voir vous donne juste un
chiffre dans nos chantiers d'insertion
quand on questionne les salariés en
insertion on découvre que 80% d'entre
eux obtiennent un nouveau droit quand il
arrive dans nos chantiers d'insertion
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
fondamental ou autres remarques sur les
précarités
je crois que vous parliez des gens qui
sont brutalement arriver c'est difficile
de venir aux restos du coeur nous dise
où des personnes accueillies il ya des
personnes qui circulent ces reculs qui
essaye de se débrouiller sans les
associations d'aidé alimentaire et ce
qui s'est passé avec cette crise c'est
que des gens qui étaient à la frontière
ou qui auraient peut-être même déjà pu
venir nous voir on vraiment basculer
d'un seul coup et c'est ça qu'il faut
prendre en compte
vous parliez du milieu rural
effectivement c'est nous aussi de nos
préoccupations on a beaucoup de soul
blanche
on peut pas couvrir l'ensemble du milieu
rural et pour les personnes font
quelquefois faire 15 km pour venir
jusqu'à un nouveau centre de
distribution c'est problématique est
donc un des des priorités de
développement en nous dans les
prochaines années
c'est des camions mobiles qui peuvent
justement parcourir les villages dans la
campagne pour pouvoir aller vers des
personnes qui aujourd'hui sont à vizille
ne sont pas comptés dans nos
statistiques parce qu'elles ne viennent
pas dans nos centres alors qu'elles
relèvent beaucoup de de cela et puis un
dernier point qui a été évoqué par le
président des banques alimentaires c'est
l'accès à l'alimentation de qualité et
locales je pense que
commencée c'est pas parce qu'on est dans
une période de crise qu'il faut qu'on
alimente les gens avec de la nourriture
bat gars ont peu varié
c'est un autre sujet de préoccupation
qu'on a développée dans certains
départements avec l'aide de quelques
collectivités locales pour acheter local
acheter local et de qualité et si
possible des produits bio c'est pas
parce qu'on est pauvre on ne doit pas
pouvoir y accéder on sait qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la nourriture bas de gamme qui est
moins cher vers lequel évidemment les
chances se dirige
s'il ya une possibilité que nous
associations d'aidé alimentaire on
puisse se permettre un meilleur accès
des publics à ce type de nourriture de
meilleure qualité on est évidemment
preneur et c'est des choses que l'on
pousse dans le cadre des débats qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur le chèque alimentaire
voire la sécurité sociale alimentaire
est évoqué ici
merci sur la terminologie d'évolution
l'hyper précarité la précarité la
pauvreté est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
s'y colle secours populaire mais celle
de nicolas jésus a vendu du mal à
répondre intégralement ce sont sur la
question de terminologie
en tout cas sur ce sujet là ce qui est
sûr c'est que oui on est un baromètre de
la de la pauvreté de la précarité
parce que pendant cette crise on l'a vu
on est un baromètre
quand on est un baromètre rapide c'est à
dire que les populations elles arrivent
chez nous une semaine quinze jours après
les annonces de confinement mais en tout
cas on a on allait nécessiter d'avoir
d'avoir une grande réactivité et et vu
que le sujet c'est l'aide alimentaire je
voulais revenir sur un point qui a été
peu évoquée c'est l'importance dans nos
réseaux de disposer de stocks
alimentaires physique alors notamment
les délais légaux et les grands
programmes c'est les programmes
européens avec ses fins dès le futur a
fait ce plus mais en tout cas d'avoir
ces produits physiquement dans nos
entrepôts ça nous a permis très
rapidement de réagir et de pouvoir
organiser les distributions alimentaires
on a vu alors l'état étaient présents
cependant le temps que la machine se met
en route on a vu des fonds déconcentré
arrivé trois mois quatre mois cinq mois
après sur les comptes bancaires de nos
associations locales donc donc
heureusement qu'on avait c'est store
pour heureusement qu'on avait ce réseau
de bénévoles qui étaient là notre
disposition pour pour agir dans la
rapidité
je vais revenir sur la question des
moyens et sur la question du du plan
france relance donc oui il ya eu 100
millions d'euros de flécher sur la sur
la lutte contre la pauvreté
ça a été débloquée en une seule fois
alors juste pour vous rappeler il ya eu
2600 projet de déposer pour un montant
de plus de 500 millions d'euros c'est
pour ça que la halle tout a été bloqué
pendant la première vague
pour moi c'est révélateur d'une chose
c'est que le monde associatif dans sa
globalité et c'est le cas de nos réseaux
et sous financée sur ses besoins de
financement structurel des restaurants
du coeur disait que la crise a révélé la
sous dotation en locaux et en moyens
d'en faire des actions c'est même un
petit peu plus large
c'est le manque de moyens pour nous
organiser et pour enfin que ça soit dans
les locaux dans l'organisation dans le
dans tout ce qui est système
d'information tout ça est relativement
compliqué donc pour souligner notre
besoin d'avoir des financements et puis
d'avoir de la lisibilité financement
notamment en termes de dotation
pluriannuel voilà et sur la terminologie
précarité pauvreté oui alors dans nos
nouveaux publics on a des gens qui
soient arrivées qui est effectivement à
la limite et qu'on bascule et ou alors
qu'ils ont été qu un certain temps chez
nous le temps de rebondir
évidemment est on est on s'en félicite
après sur le ski tu qualifies quelqu'un
deux envois de précarisation de vraiment
pauvre pour nous c'est là la longueur de
présence en au dispositif en fait donc
ça on le saura avec le temps
merci yano j'ai ouï écoutez je vais pas
réagir sur sur tous les points sur
toutes vos questions sur la votre
interrogation sur le sur le vocabulaire
et sur la qualification des publics
précaires
je ne sais pas s'ils répondent aux
questions mais je le trouve que les
différences de vocabulaire illustre
aussi simplement le fait que les
associations ici présentes ne s'adresse
pas tout et c'est mieux au même type de
public les mêmes situations de fragilité
le public qui fréquente une épicerie
dans lequel et de fondant dans laquelle
pardon il va faire ses courses pour de
30% de la valeur marchande est pas le
même qu un public qui va fréquenter un
centre de distribution pour repas à
chaud principalement pour des personnes
sans domicile fixe ou mouche caricature
énormément mais voilà juste pour que le
que le propose soit clair donc moi ça ne
me surprend pas que ne qualifie pas les
situations de la même manière et je
trouve que cet état de fait que vous
soulignez ne fait finalement que mettre
en évidence mais quelque chose qui me
surprend depuis depuis un an et demi que
je suis dans le secteur que le regarde
encore avec un oeil presque neuf c'est
l'absence totale de planification des
réponses en fonction des différentes
situations de précarité pense que c'est
très complexe à mettre en place puisque
les associations de sont autonomes
chacune leur approche spécifique et nous
compris les néanmoins un aucun moment il
y a une autorité qui prend en main le
sujet en qualifiant le besoin réel des
aides alimentaires et on le segment
temps et on est en réfléchissant aux
moyens à mettre en face c'est sa part
est trivial ce que le dit mais je ne
crois pas que ça fonctionne comme ça
aujourd'hui et peut-être elles sont
encore à un moment où la précarité
explosent et où les fragilités de nos
organisations année aux uns et aux
autres sont mis en évidence
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire sur 7
sur 7 s est ensuite vous nous interroger
sur notre capacité à mesurer les besoins
non pourvus en toute objectivité 20 je
réponds pour ce qui nous concerne je ne
pense que nous sommes incapables de
faire ce travail là il ya un lien avec
avec le précédent jeu j'ai évoqué par
définition nous le voyons que les les
personnes qui frappent à la porte de nos
dispositifs
après ces personnes sont acceptés ou non
à la limite on peut fournir de la
lisibilité sur les personnes que nous ne
sommes pas en mesure d'accompagner et
pour le reste je vois là je pense que
c'est un travail à part entière une
mission à part entière
peut-être que les très très grande
association ou une emprise territoriale
et une vision sur les besoins tellement
larges qu'elles saurait répondre à ces
interrogations
mais je ne crois pas que la majorité
d'entre nous ont soit on soit capable
et puis enfin sur la première question
est un petit peu en vrac les sons
prétendre être exhaustif donc on
répondra à vos questions
je nous interroger sur sur la
problématique
fais ton face à des situations de non
recours au droit ou est ce qu'on a en
face une réelle hausse eux d'essayer
besoin je tire un petit peu le trait
mais c'était votre votre votre question
je ne sais pas si on est en mesure d'y
répondre et mot puisque avant même la
crise qui on regarde les ordres de
grandeurs l'aide alimentaire devrait au
mieux 50 % des besoins des personnes
sous le seuil de pauvreté
si on manipule c'est l'ordre de grandeur
sauf erreur on était à peu près sur huit
millions de personnes sous le seuil de
pauvreté et 5,5 millions qui seraient
quand l aide alimentaire avec de très
probables double on a assez massif dans
ses comptes
donc grosso modo on peut considérer que
50 % d'aidés publiques ne fréquentait
pas l'aide alimentaire alors qu'il ne
pourrait y avoir droit et avoir une
appréciation dynamique de l'évolution de
ce ratio avec la rapidité de l'évolution
de la situation de la pauvreté
lassus bien incapable de vous répondre
mais ce point de départ et ses ordres de
grandeur et initiaux sous très très
clair
bon là pour fournir quelques éléments au
débat j'en profite pour vous dire que si
les discussions se poursuivre après 16
heures je serai là ce contraints de
quitter
mais on envisageait éventuellement de
déborder une petite dizaine de minutes
au maximum parce qu'on a ensuite
d'autres intervenants est ce que
certains d'entre vous veulent réagir aux
propos de madame la présidente
oui monsieur claude baland avant de
passer la parole à madame à force
apourceau poly par nord je voudrais
essayer parce que je dis bien sied parce
que tout ça c'est très subjectif
répondre à votre question pourquoi les
besoins alimentaires cruciaux en milieu
rural soit en moins bien pourvus qu'ils
ne le sont dans les grandes métropoles
où les banlieues je pense qu'il ya déjà
un problème de mentalité
donc c'est là que j'ai tout subjectif la
pauvreté est minorée l'insuffisance
alimentaire les besoins alimentaires
d'abord parce que dans l'idée compris
des ruraux être à la campagne ça veut
dire ça sous-entend autoconsommation on
nage son jardin ce qui n'est plus vrai
de de beaucoup de personnes
et deuxièmement toujours dans la même
subjectivité la pauvreté est interprété
comme une insuffisance personnel s'il en
est là c'est qu'il n'a pas dû beaucoup
se bouger troisièmement il y à certains
maires à cause de ces deux
interprétations de la pauvreté
alimentaire qui vous répondent j'ai bien
dit certain à bages dans ma commune n'y
a pas de pauvres
donc quand vous essayer d'élaborer un
réseau par où passait ou déposer ou
déposés les colis ont même un nom chez
nous y'a pas de pot et troisièmement
quatrièmement il y a un problème il n'ya
pas d'anonymat
imaginez un quart avec les restos du
coeur charybde en un mot concrètement
fait ça excusez moi j'habite un village
les rideaux ce sous légèrement c'est pas
possible et intel
il bénéficie de l'aide alimentaire ils
sont pas si pour que ça et ceux qui en
bénéficient ont vis-à-vis des voisins et
quatrièmement il y a une grande pudeur
excusez moi là c'est un jugement de
valeur qui se discute
une assez grande une très grande pudeur
c'est de dire on n'ose pas on ne s'est
pas révélé qu on al qu'on a le besoin
qu'on a besoin d'eux qu'on peut pas
subvenir à ses besoins alimentaires
c'est pour ça que je crois par exemple
mais ça se discute que si on distribuait
si un jour le chèque alimentaires des
formes alimentaire c'était une carte
magnétique pour acheter par exemple des
produits bio moi je pense que le
bénéficiaire n'oserait pas aller dans un
rayon de 5 ou 10 km autour de chez lui
chez l'agriculteur bio en disant mais
voilà moi je veux acheter sur cette
carte parce qu'il révélerait qu'il est
en situation de nonda de dépendances
donc voilà toutes les raisons pour
lesquelles je pense qu'ils en ont besoin
dans l'est avec des agriculteurs en
retraite qui ont qui ont les retraites
que vous savez 1 700 euros 800 euros
parfois ils peuvent plus faire leur
jardin et je pense qu'il ya une misère
aussi forte que dans les banlieues et
dans les grandes métropoles mais qui est
moins couvertes
la sénatrice apourceau poly également sa
réponse est facile de la part d'un scoop
c'est bon là non non la maison à s'il
faut que ce soit rouge ça m'arrange
eagle bon
merci madame la présidente alors il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
évidemment nous sommes aujourd'hui pour
parler de la précarité alimentaire
je suis de celles qui pense et je sais
beaucoup de que beaucoup de collègues ne
rejoigne mais que la pauvreté que la
précarité ce n'est pas qu'alimentaire
la précarité elle est aussi quand on n'a
pas accès au logement elle est aussi
quand on n'a pas accès aux soins à la
prévention aux vacances 1 à l'énergie à
l'eau c'est aussi de la pauvreté de la
précarité quand malheureusement nous
n'avons pas accès à toutes ces choses
qui devraient des droits pour chaque
citoyen alors nous on est beaucoup
moi je les fais dans mon département
j'habite je pas de calais en jour assure
monsieur ya pas un maire qui me dit qu a
pas de pauvres tensions dans sa ville en
à 900 communes et malheureusement on est
dans un département touché par la crise
très fortement mais comme plein d'autres
mais plein fouet
et puis avec une ruralité à 60 3 363%
donc du département du pas de calais
rural et donc je voulais poser une une
question sur la pauvreté en milieu rural
mais je vous remercie parce que je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce que vous
avez dit sur sur la pauvreté en milieu
rural
alors j'ai moi même rencontré les
associations et on me dit alors
localement et y compris dans un
département qui lie à un bon et on l'a
entendu lors de précédentes auditions
sur les travailleurs pauvres
actuellement beaucoup de travailleurs
sont en train de basculer
donc dans la pauvreté beaucoup de gens
qui gagnent le smic qui ont eu donc du
chômage partiel même si le smic a été
rémunéré à 100% avec le chômage partiel
ceci dit ils ont perdu leurs primes 1
ils ont perdu leurs primes et donc eh
bien quand on gagne 300 euros par mois
et qu'on perd 2 300 euros et quand on
gagne 5000 euros et bien c'est pas la
même chose je veux dire quand on gagne
5000 euros et qu'on en perd mille et
quand on en gagne 1300 qu'on en perd 300
peau de suite le ratio n'est pas le même
donc je devrais savoir
vous confirmez que il y a eu un bon de
travailleurs pauvres qui se sont
adressés à vaut donc à vos associations
caritatives
et puis par rapport j'ai entendu
quelqu'un parler de la loi coluche je
suis moi même de plus en plus sollicitée
par donc les restos du coeur mais qui
sont souvent quand même installé dans
les municipalités et par le secours
populaire sur le manque de locaux alors
apparemment même les bailleurs sociaux
ont du mal à répondre à vos demandes
un même si parfois vous arrivez à payer
un petit loyer si l'association
on me dit que les bailleurs sociaux ont
beaucoup de mal à répondre à vos
demandes de deux locaux voilà et on sait
bien qu'un comité
malheureusement doit être dans la
proximité parce que généralement quand
on est pauvre être précaire
eh bien on n'a pas les moyens de se
déplacer et notamment quand on est en
ruralité et même quand on est dans
l'urbain on n'a parfois pas les moyens
de se déplacer parce que la mobilité et
bien ce n'est pas gagné dans nos
départements
voilà donc je voulais savoir ce que vous
pensez de cette loi et comment on
pourrait qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous feriez si vous n'étiez à notre
place comme projet de loi pourra pour
avoir avoir des locaux pour vos
associations
comment imaginez-vous siens alors une
question sur le public et sur une
question sur l'évolution de la loi
monsieur dufour un seul sénateur
merci madame la présidente donc merci à
tous les intervenants ou six présidents
d'associations caritatives
eu égard à ce qu'avaient indiqué
d'autres collègues sur la loi concernant
le logement
je poserai une autre question banquiers
qui peut paraître peut-être anecdotique
mais enfin qui est important aussi
vous avez cité effectivement de
nombreuses personnes qui venaient ce qui
est à la crise du couvent idée n'est pas
que fréquentait sociation niveau des
aides
mais avez-vous un critère quels critères
vous utilisez pour faire face aux
demandes parce qu'il ya des personnes
qui pourraient demander qui n'ont pas
besoin et inversement aussi merci on va
prendre toute la question je crois que
même la sénatrice jacques mais vous avez
aussi une question et ensuite on va vous
répondre et à l'ensemble des grands oui
merci merci bien sûr pour toutes les
informations que nous avons eu des
différentes associations
monsieur ballan vous avez cité quelques
chiffres qui m'ont interpellé notamment
la baisse brutale de la ramasse un vous
parlez de moi 32% -47% c'est des
chiffres qui que je trouve considérable
et dans le département du doubs il ya
emmaüs qui à faire don de 3000 euros à
la banque alimentaire justement est-ce
que vous pensez que pour essayer de
combler un petit peu cette diminution
que vous constaté au niveau de la
ramasser une autre orientation que vous
pourriez envisager pour justement
trouver plus de produits et la deuxième
chose vous avez parlé de l'articulation
entre les différents réseaux de
distributeurs qu'on peut faire mieux
alors là je vous rejoins parce que avant
j'étais vice président du conseil
départemental du doubs en charge
justement des solidarités et on avait
cette difficulté alliés et à mailler les
différentes associations qui s'occupent
justement de ce problème alimentaire
alors quelles solutions
si vous en avez pouvez vous m mettre en
avant pour justement essayer que les
différentes associations se parler
travaillent mieux ensemble de temps vous
n'avez pas les mêmes critères 1
certaines structures ont des critères
bien précis
d'autres ne l'ont pas ils n'en demandent
pas et voilà et en plus comment peut-on
faire pour savoir c'est certaines
personnes ne tape à plusieurs portes ou
pas et si effectivement il y a
il ya un équilibre qui ce qui se fait
entre les différentes demandes
merci alors est-ce qu en visio il ya une
association qui souhaite de prendre la
parole
je peux peut-être et on répondra à
quelques questions sur les travailleurs
pauvres bo a pas de chiffres précis sur
la question
ce que je peux vous dire et on en a
d'ailleurs parlé dans les médias c'est
que sur nos activités de rue on a vu
effectivement pendant le premier
confinement arriver des personnes qui
dans le petit boulot avait cessé
immédiatement ou des travailleurs
pauvres du style les livreurs hubert
ritz et ses acquis se retrouver
brutalement sans activité et qui ne
l'est plus tôt de solutions que de venir
nous voir
mais bon voilà je n'ai pas de chiffres
plus précis mais c'est vrai que des
travailleurs on en avait avant la crise
et la tendance ne peut être que dans que
dans l'augmentation il a été question
des critères d'accès de l'aide à l'aide
alimentaire chez nous le seul critère
c'est une question c'est un barème on a
une question de revenus on regarde le
revenu des personnes et on enlève le
loyer les charges de loyer et le reste à
vivre et comparer un barème en fonction
de la proposition de la famille on a
accès ou pas à l'aide alimentaire qui
est en moyenne de six repas par semaine
et par et par personne n'offre pas pour
les célibataires
je le dis parce que les personnes qui
viennent nous voir en jeu 14 fois par
semaine sans parler du petit déjeuner et
donc il y a effectivement des personnes
accueillies qui vont dans plusieurs
associations c'est très bien je veux
dire on serait assez choqué s'il fallait
faire la police et dire toi tu vas au
secours populaire donc tu viendras pas
aux restos du coeur ou inversement s'il
ya des gens qui sont vraiment dans une
une difficulté extrêmement aigu et il
est normal qu'ils tapent a plusieurs
cordes pour arriver à s'en sortir un
petit peu parce que ce que nous leur
donnons jeudi quand même pas du luxe
la question des locaux les locaux la
plupart du temps aux restos sont mis à
disposition par des collectivités
locales il est rare que ce soit les
bailleurs sociaux qui nous les met à
disposition la plupart du temps aussi
s'est mise à disposition à titre gratuit
et c'est important pour nous parce que
ce que l'on passe d'envoyer c'est
quelque chose que l'on passera pas dans
l'aide dans l'aide aux personnes et on
paye et en général les charges
la difficulté c'est pas de trouver des
locaux en général c'est de trouver des
locaux adaptés à notre activité
je les dis au tout début de cette séance
nous avons dû mettre en veilleuse ou en
tout cas adapté dans des conditions
dégradées toutes les activités
d'inclusion sociale que nous faisons
dans nos centres de distribution et
aujourd'hui le facteur limitant
principal c'est bien les locaux donnent
un exemple dans beaucoup de centres on
donne des cours de français si on a une
salle qui avec les normes d'hygiène ne
peut accepter que quatre personnes alors
qu'elles en accepter 10 ou 12 auparavant
mais on est obligé de limiter cette
activité d' aide à la personne et c'est
un sujet qui pour nous est crucial sur
lequel on alerte les élus locaux on
alerte les préfets pour essayer de nous
de nous donner accès à des locaux mieux
adaptés à nos activités
enfin dernier dernier point qui a été
évoqué
mallet les différentes associations qui
ont entendu dire qu'il fallait qu'elle
se parle dans là je vous rassure en bout
nous parlons en permanence et pas
simplement dans les réunions nationales
personnellement je suis dans un
département où l'entrepôt des restos
était à 300 mètres de celui de la banque
alimentaire de chaque fois que nous
avions des surplus trop importante pour
être écoulée avant les dates limites on
les échanger avec la banque alimentaire
et réciproquement ce genre de choses on
le fait alors ensuite aller plus loin
dans le rapprochement
je dirais attention à deux choses
d'abord effectivement nous avons des
principes qui sont dus à notre histoire
qui ont chacun leur légitimité je pense
à la gratuité
la gratuité est un principe chez les
restos
c'est pas forcément le cas ailleurs je
ne dis pas qu'on a raison reste du monde
mais c'est comme ça chacun a sa sas et
ses principes chacun a sa diversité il
dirait la diversité des associations est
une richesse qu'il ne faudrait pas à
couvrir en voulant absolument de tout
coordonner tout centraliser tous mpt
uniformisé c'est un peu comme en
écologie ou l'avion diversité c'est une
richesse pour s'adapter aux évolutions
et et réagir aux agressions et aux
perturbations mais je crois que dans le
milieu associatif c'est plutôt une
richesse d'avoir une multitude
d'associations qui sont sur le terrain
qu'ils se parlent qui se coordonnent
pendant cette période de crise qui nous
réunit je peux vous dire que nous avons
été contactés pour par différentes
associations pour pouvoir leur apporter
des dents et je pense notamment dans le
cadre des hôtels sociaux qui ont été
réquisitionnés pour mettre à l'abri des
personnes qui étaient devant je pense
aux associations d'étudiants que nous
avons contactés on a su nous adapter à
cette nouvelle réalité
il faut il faut voir le côté positif des
choses et ne pas penser qu'une
centralisation permanente serait une
amélioration
honnêtement nous le croyons merci oui je
crois
ballan a été je verrai cessé d'être poli
je perds et feront de consommables la
sénatrice folie vous pouvez vous tourner
le dos à vous alors madame vous avez
annoncé que vous avez à me poser de
questions la baisse de la ramasse
d'abord est-ce qu'elle peut être
compensée par d'autres formes de dons
oui ça l'a été pendant le lac aux eaux
vives
puisque je vous ai dit qu'il y avait eu
une explosion de générosité et
maintenant des industriels ali serait
longue
ça dépend du département barry harris
danone etc etc qui ont appelé d'eux
mêmes en dix ans voilà j'ai des stocks
parfois qu'ils pouvaient pas bande à
cause du peaufinement n'ont pas une
grande générosité
ce n'était pas lié aussi par les aides
qu'on a appelé les aides qu'ovide
exceptionnelle de l'état mais le
problème c'est que cette ramasse était
une ressource pérenne et moi je ne sais
pas si d'ailleurs dès le deuxième
semestre générosité des industries
alimentaires et des grandes coopératives
agricoles
c'est pas une critique mais ce sont
diminués par rapport à ce qu'elle avait
été
entre mars et 2020 c'est ce qui est
inquiétant
est ce que j'ai pas souligner c'est
aussi bien une baisse en quantité
kiko qui continue et qui s'accroît
qu'une baisse en qualité parce que un
grand groupe que je ne citerai pas parce
que je veux stigmatiser personne mais
avait des difficultés à l'époque il a dû
faire des économies pour ne pas
remplacer du personnel donc le tri était
d'une très mauvaise qualité beaucoup de
bea m'ont dit mais ce qui arrive de tels
grands magasins vraiment tout est à
acheter
on peut jeter 85% de ce qu'on nous donne
je parle évidemment des fruits des
fruits et des légumes et des plats et
des plats cuisinés et surtout que c'est
des causses pérenne la diminution de la
ramasse
il ya une meilleure gestion des stocks
il ya aussi des éléments positifs
c'était les grandes et moyennes surfaces
achètent de plus en plus localement avec
des produits qui seront frais qui se
perd et nikki ceux qui sont pas à biner
il ya les solderies il ya les
départements où on vend à bon prix les
les aliments qui arrive à l'appréhension
mais aussi des éléments qu'on peut dire
moi je lui ai dis donc c'est pas une
critique ce qu'on peut appeler même si
ça a été une grande avancée
certains effets pervers dit de la loi
garraud ou certains une grande surface
préfèrent vendre à des soldeurs killer
traite tous les problèmes de réductions
d'impôts que donner à des banques
alimentaires et aux autres grands
réseaux donc c'est un vraiment un vrai
problème qui nous inquiète et qui menace
l'avenir
eh ben ça j'ai commencé en tant de sa
partir du 1er confinement mais c'est
exister j'étais tendancielle et pour
andy 2010 9 44% des produits qu'on
redistribue et venait des grandes et
moyennes surfaces et déjà en 2020 ya
plus que 38% vous voyez que la baisse
est assez forte 38% des produits données
viennent de ce qu'on appelle la halle à
la ramasse alors maintenant la
coopération qu'est ce que ça peut être
concrètement à la coopération
d'abord je réponds aux collègues et des
restos du coeur
effectivement ça existait déjà je veux
donner des exemples rapidement
deuxièmement mais aussi on peut dire ça
dépend quand même de la personnalité et
du président db à et du président des
restos du coeur ou de tous les collègues
qui sont là il y en a dont c'est l'état
d'esprit de coopérer d'authie coopèrent
moines et 300 sites et même si le tram
minoritaire il ya encore des effets
d'affichage digne ou nikon
et on avait prêté un jour un camion à
une de nos grandes associations
partenaires n'avaient pas assez de
camions nous avons du camion alors le
président de la baie a dit ah bon on a
acheter un neuf ah ben non mais tu
comprends je préfère payer mon logo sur
le camion bon c'est ultra minoritaire
c'est symbolique mais je pense que l'on
peut encore faire au mieux même si ça
existe déjà
soit on peut faire des actions en commun
je ne les détails pas il ya des
distributions pendant le premier
confinement le premier confinement a été
très grave mais finalement il a été un
accélérateur parfois d'initiatives
sociales positives dans une ville comme
châteauroux on a distribué dans certains
quartiers directement avec les restos du
coeur on n'a jamais fait les choses tout
seul c'est toujours été fait avec
d'autres vous avez entendu plairait la
distribution en milieu rural pour le
morbihan cet effet en pleine
concertation avec la croix rouge
l'été à bordeaux mais pas seulement
depuis le confinement
c'est la tradition que tous les grands
réseaux demande au béa de distribuer à
leurs adhérents ils nous envoient entre
églises adhérents leur usage et nous on
a les listes
et pour compenser le nécessaire légitime
des parents raconte de bénévoles c'est
les banques alimentaires et distribue
depuis deux mois on a créé des épiceries
sociales en commun entre autres pour les
étudiants et aussi à chaque fois qu'on
lance des initiatives pour le
distribution en milieu rural sait jamais
tout seul c'est toujours avec une grande
association c'est soit des
mutualisations par action soit des
mutualisations par équipement on a des
toons les mêmes tendances on essaie de
créer un niveau régional de
mutualisation donc ça peut être par
exemple un autre pot commun pour stocker
au niveau de la région d chacun nos
stocks on les mélange pas qui après sont
répartis par exemple pour les bear entre
les différentes bea ça peut être le prêt
d'un camion
etc etc donc ça existe déjà on a au
niveau national des très bonnes
relations d' écoute on se voit
régulièrement mais je pense que parfois
ça pourrait être plus voilà ce que je
voulais dire simplement tant que ce soit
la moindre critique pour les autres
parce qu'on sait inclus dedans ça dépend
des personnalités des présidents ou des
baies à ou des autres merci à chacun
d'entre vous c'est vrai que c'est aussi
la richesse de toutes les associations
chacune a sa personnalité et chacune a
aussi ses manières de faire je vous
remercie très sincèrement je vois leur
tournée donc on va devoir clore cet
échange
merci à tous pour vos contributions et
certaines réponses sont par manque de
temps n'ont pas été complète peut-être
vous pourriez nous transmettre par écrit
les réponses au questionnaire qui nous
ont qui vous ont été transmis mais aussi
aux questions qui ont été posées par nos
sénateurs et sénatrices présent à
écouter merci à tous je vous souhaite
une bonne continuation et merci à tous
nos bénévoles et parce que je pense que
par les temps qui courent c'est
effectivement un engagement très
important et qui est incontournable et
on ne pourrait pas faire sans sans votre
travail au quotidien auprès des
personnes qui sont les plus en besoin et
donc on se doit aussi d'être auprès
d'eux merci à vous merci merci au revoir
[Musique]